okay four people joining this livestream
we are talking about data set today and
we're working on a bunch of enhancements
to this so let's go ahead um so this is
a document it's similar to something
you've seen before but this is a new
proposal and it's much refined you
should take a look at that terminology
that the proposal talks about specs
paths and path specs well I'm not going
to go through that form until
capitalization but let me try to I know
you don't like that but I mean it's just
this document that's okay
okay but so what's this so this is
options so just about any any data set
option needs to refer to elements or
levels within the data set and I have a
way of repeating values on the
right-hand side and this is about that
syntax so a similar way that specs work
and data and grid okay how similar to
the way that specs work in grid um
pretty similar bit data set needs an
extended syntax time to work because
it's deeper than grids because it's
deeper as the main thing yeah okay well
let's understand the syntax oh so this
syntax is compatible with the grid
syntax is that a statement yes I have I
I have examples of that later in this
document okay all right okay so so let's
just try to understand what we're trying
to do here so I see I see so this is a
pure spec and then there's some kind of
path based spec is that correct yeah
okay all right
you know I'll open all those sections
okay you can just open all the sections
in the entire notebook the easiest to do
this command shift open square bracket
doesn't why do we need that why does it
need the dynamics and what the heck's
going on that you didn't evaluate the
initialization so value with
initialization and then close the reopen
the notebook and they'll be okay but
this should never happen no no this is
just a prototype
you need to set that path and then load
some stuff to make it this word oh I see
I have to do this okay well something
changed yeah now close the notebook and
reopen okay now you are fixing this
problem with data set that or maybe
you've already fixed it that when it is
in a notebook
it may not you know it may not have the
appropriate data to be able to go to the
next page and things
yep that's fixed okay and it's also
fixed in the cloud
there's nothing well it's fixed in a
branch okay I understand it hasn't been
pulled yet okay okay all right
oh come on oh okay
what are those gray blobs there that's
just a placeholder in the prototype you
can ignore them they won't order what
they give me a place to attach menus to
you can you can right-click on that and
there's a menu but how will you do that
in real in the real situation is yet to
be resolved that's why there's a
placeholder right now okay
but so that does need to be an anchor
for right-clicking at that position as
that's correct later right why aren't
you just right clicking somewhere in
that cell and being happy that would be
nice you would think it would be a
trivial thing to do but it's not that
entire area sensitive okay well so
that's in front end is to you right yeah
so you should just deal with that we're
not gonna spend some weird things no no
no it's just a placeholder it's just
something that I haven't had time to
attend to yet okay okay so this is a
path spec version where the background I
don't really like that pink but let's
just check the design that's oh come on
what is this it's just the
initialization what hey okay there you
go okay fine
okay so there's there's two basic kinds
of options options that effect items and
options that effect headers this show
this drilled all the way down because
inside the earth yes everything every
descendant of Earth huh as opposed to
merely the top-level how would I specify
merely the top-level of Earth if you
give just the top level so I mean what
would that mean it means only color the
things that appear as direct I mean this
is a list of associations only appear
the thing only color the things that
appear I mean so this thing at the top
level on the right-hand side of the
Earth Association is that what you mean
that's what I mean because otherwise I
would expect this
peace including the moon label to be
affected you're only affecting the
values here absolutely and I think
that's the right thing to do you want to
treat the headers differently than the
items right there isn't a way to color
only the top level earth things and I
don't I mean you could do them
individually because I earth mass and
earth radius yeah well okay so fine so
what are you showing me here you're
showing me this is just I mean you just
step through this this sequence here
it's just sort of a top level
introduction to how everything generally
works so there's item options there are
header options and then you can use
paths to get to specific elements okay
and if you want to refer to an entire
row or column you use all yeah just like
you would I mean so this for example if
I do this right and if I say this yeah
and then I say brackets all come a
radius exactly
okay those are precisely the things
though then colored it makes sense yes
okay
and then header options work similarly
if you want a color in the header of
that column you use all radius why do I
need the IC IC because they need them
yeah you so you can just use radius but
a bit that's ambiguous because there are
two radius columns right if you do that
both of them will be colored pink so in
other words you're saying without a path
spec if I were to just do this so this
is a convenient syntax it's kind of an
exception but I think is handy you know
that it's also ambiguous well I assume
this would also work okay all right
let's go on okay so you just explained
the principle that this works on which
is that the the path specifies what you
would get if you use to extract to
extract that part of the data set great
makes sense now what about the head is
the head so the for the header options
it's the header of the things that would
be extracted okay makes sense okay so
the syntax overview that this goes
deeper into all the ins and outs of the
syntax okay let me let me
see which ones I don't understand him
why'd you open them second oh this is
the thing okay okay
background pink I don't understand that
why oh I see that's the content areas
background only yes so if I would say
header background to pink I hate this
pink yes okay now if I wanted to do just
the UM just these top-level headers at
the top here you can continue down this
overview that gets to that I want to try
see if I can figure it out myself okay
so that should be yeah that should just
be all arrow pink now okay why isn't
that all arrow pink because that should
be selecting all those rows and the head
of that spec has to be in paren and
brackets do I have to say all all like
that okay so you've got columns if you
have one order to be rows yeah okay okay
now if I'm
to extract the headers from the data set
how would I do that it's there's not
really a me use keys it's kind of
convoluted what would I actually have to
do
you'd have to extract the level that you
want the keys of and then apply keys to
it I'm wondering if we shouldn't have a
thing that's called headers header
extract or something in which you just
give this thing all comma all and it
just returns that list of headers so I'm
saying yeah I just like extract would
return the content area right I think we
should consider that I think it would be
a nice thing too I think it'd be useful
to be able to get the headers out would
it make sense to use keys as a keyword
possibly yeah possibly so that would be
something for your agenda I would say
yeah yeah yeah yeah why not like a key
extract that's better than how to
extract I agree
he extract well I was actually thinking
about putting keys somewhere in where
you have placed all like okema keys I
see I see I see I see I see so extract
um data set well I don't know whether
the word Keys is quite the right one but
something like that right some keyboard
that says go to the keys yeah why not I
mean because we have the notion I mean
in a sense if we have extract f of X Y
comma 0
we'll get F and this is kind of the
analog of that right we're gonna do
cedar because we would get association
ekran oh I understand I understand but
but that's that's the notion is it's the
um okay all right let's keep going
so that's an interesting notion if we
had that kind of syntax having header
background exactly I'm not sure we want
to avoid it I think it's a convenient
concept to have but I agree that I think
we should I mean this will be an
alternative way to get to it and it
might be useful if we have to replicate
header on some other options which are
less common um I might be a good way to
deal with that okay all rows should be
pink okay fine okay first row pink and
that's fine why does the pink have to be
in braces because the the first element
refers to rows or the first level the
data set the second element of first two
columns at the second level and so forth
otherwise there's an ambiguity if it
were just a naked list is it a list of
specs as or is it a list of or is it a
self of spec and I've resolved it by
saying the right-hand side is always a
listeners and it's not the same way that
grid resolves it well a grid doesn't
have this issue and grid it's always a
list of row column I see or actually in
grid I think it's column row which is
unfortunate it doesn't match data set
what's it going to be in table view
sorry I still don't understand if I said
none come a pinky what would that mean
well you can do it it'll it'll work in
that case because pink is a shorthand
for so pink just means make globally
everything pink or in this case it means
make the first no it didn't do the same
thing well okay okay
oh no sorry sorry that was the wrong
explanation so this means make this is
just like grid it means make the first
item of that level pink so it's making
the first column pink what it's just
like I see so if I were to do this if I
would say instead of just pink there I
would just say pink , yellow then I
would get I see that's great right fair
enough
and what do ya it's so that you're
talking about columns rather than rows
if you remove it or not it would apply
that to rows right so then it will be
the Venus will be pink and earth will be
yellow looks good okay sorry but
shouldn't be all then because none seems
to be suggesting don't take any columns
no all of them none means don't apply
any value it's this is this is nothing
to pass back this is none would be on
the left-hand side yeah okay so the
later things take precedence yeah
or is it more specific things take
precedence no later things okay
oh boy so this is a cyclic thing which
probably we should have had a wrapper
for we should have a wrapper don't we
have a wrapper in in permutations for
this cycles bla bla bla
no so consistent notation of the
permutation itself we have discussed in
the past having a structure or a type
called cyclic array yes or / petach
array or something like that which I
think we should consider um okay but I
think this is okay for now okay
background noise okay looking good so I
don't feel like there is one use case
that you know if you want to give
background color for both header and the
column say like if I want mass I want to
highlight the header as well as the
values in here yeah I agree that's
fairly ugly now what you want to you
want a color that those headers as well
as the items the whole the whole big
chunk you know the whole big row they're
not this situation here where you've got
this is uncolored but it's content is
colored this wants to go across the
whole thing here now if we had a way of
referring I mean so we could imagine
okay so for example here's a possible
thing we can imagine doing here if we
said something like this so right now if
I say earth goes to saya and I get that
right yeah but what Sushma wants you
know we could imagine Earth comma Keys
goes to cyan colors just the headers and
we could imagine that something like
earth comma full goes to cyan does
oh wait a minute so earth comma keys
earth would reply would have refer to
rows and keys would refer to columns and
your example oh okay well how do I get
you want to say something like earth
yeah earth earth items and keys is what
you're trying to say no in that
particular case I'm trying to say in
this case here I'm simply saying color
that particular thing which I could get
by saying header background arrow I
believe I can get through this can't I
yes okay so now the issue is if I were
to do the following thing if I were to
do this and that then that will do
almost what sushma once except that it
still missed the moon which you can add
try could add right but the issue is if
I just want to take that whole I agree
with you I I don't understand why
background doesn't apply to the header
by default to go what I'm saying
yeah but III why isn't it that whole row
including its header that gets colored
well that's I can take that into
consideration see if there's a way of
generalizing the syntax to do that well
or having the even the default it's not
obvious to me that default is right yeah
I mean it's one thing to do that it's
one thing to do the default if you have
a path spec in the case of a pure spec I
don't really see it necessarily right I
mean I would be what you know what do
spreadsheets do for this do they
highlight the the row specifier as well
I think they do I'm
a spreadsheet user I think in
spreadsheet we can fill each cell but
not the header but not that I think I
don't know enough to actually comment on
that but no but header can be filled to
I I mean what I'm saying is I don't know
if I can just you know select the entire
row and color everything the same that
is something I need to I mean it's okay
but I mean the question is when you do
that
does it also color the header or does it
only color the content okay I can find
that out yes right but I tend to think
that coloring the the header as well is
the most useful thing to do okay okay
this is where it'd be lovely if there
are people on our live stream who have
comments about this we'd love to hear
them
yeah I'm either there or everybody's
quiet today
okay everybody is to sport out of their
mind with this topic which they
shouldn't be um okay okay okay
you
okay so this case that is a Content item
and what happens if you specify the
header I mean I could imagine that you
would specify the triangulation so to
speak on to that item that is um you
know earth and radius yeah I could do
that why not
seems useful sandal on our live stream
says this seems like an Excel feature
he's not sure how much this is all going
to be used um we'll see I think if it's
nicely done it will be used and I think
also another question is whether we're
going to have an attached cell for this
data set where you can select things I
mean what you know whether we should be
thinking of an attached cell for data
sets just like we haven't attached cell
for images for example or what
functionality would be enlisted oh no I
don't know I mean it's things to do with
selection it's just kind of a user
discovery type thing yeah but I think we
should consider that we haven't
discussed doing that but I mean we could
certainly imagine extracting particular
rows and columns and so on which you can
do it already
of course of course but you have to know
the syntax I mean no just it's in the
menus in the header menus there's
there's copy right right-click on a
header so a copy position or paste
position
for awful what is that it's it's just
broken in the in this prototype okay is
there a way of discovering um let's see
so so if I say copy data to clipboard
it's not gonna work or that and also
there may be broken as well okay okay
let's keep going
right so there's a slight difference
here which I'm not entirely happy with
so for items if you just specified
background pink everything's pink if you
specify all rose pink that has the same
effect because every item is in a row
right those are those are equivalent
syntaxes for headers is different if you
sped if you say all header is paying
bills deeply yeah it does it does what
you expect all headers are pink but if
you put it in a list so that it only
refers to row is only the row headers or
pink okay so that means if you if you
try to use the header background option
to specify a global value of pink and a
local value of something else
it probably won't behave the way you
expect because the first pink is going
to apply only to the row headers so
there's not really a way within a list
of specs to specify a global value that
applies to everything you can always
specify values that apply to levels
particular levels I think that's I don't
think that's great but I don't have a
solution yet okay hold on why is this
different for headers and for actual
backgrounds because oh I see actual
backgrounds as soon as you did the row
one it's just global because every item
is in both a row and a column
whereas for headers are either in a row
or a column okay
I see well I mean of course
changes its complexion if you do this
thing of defaulting to in this case
defaulting to also color the the headers
yeah and then you have to undo that by
having a head of background to none for
something no that would not undo it
header background nag means just let
whatever value is phosphide previously
perfectly so then what would so head of
head of background our automatic would
have to be the thing that undoes yeah
yeah that would read will that do it now
sure okay oh boy okay all right so I
think that particular issue yeah let's
keep going let's come back to that
because I think it's affected so this is
what I mentioned earlier if the left
hand side is not a list which indicates
a path then it just it gives you a
convenient way of referring to headers
if they're unique if they're not unique
it's kind of weird but it's okay it's
it's you I mean especially for headers
you don't always want to what's that
hello
you just did sorry my my phone was
ringing I commuted yeah I mean just just
it's just a convenience so that
sometimes you just want to say me you
know if earth if earth is unique you
just want to say makers you know yeah
yeah yes we talked about this already
yep so you should look at the last
example there so you can use none so if
you make the first row pink you can use
none on the columns back to let the row
color show through what so that's that
called the column spec says make columns
alternately cyan and none if it's none
then whatever the color the previous
prevailing color shows through as
opposed to that being automatic doing
that but as opposed to being automatic
or being white or whatever so what would
automatic do in this case it'll make a
white because because why it's the
default oops that's surprising that's
probably a bug
okay fine all right but so automatic
goes to the base default not to the
proximate now a coloration delay
Stephane yeah that's a good point
from sander here um wouldn't it be cool
if you could color the background based
on values that is to have a background
function that is a good idea
I can imagine a background function that
would take values I mean I agree I've
needed that a bunch of times and I built
that and it's kind of a nuisance to go
out to get something which will actually
fill the the cells so to speak yeah it's
a good idea let's let's talk about that
in a minute let's see if we can I mean
in other words what that would be is
something which needs two pieces of
information and maybe they're part of
background itself it needs the piece of
information yeah in fact I mean one can
imagine it being part of background
because on the one hand you're saying
this is the location and then on the
other hand you're saying and there's
also a value function that does
something mm-hmm so in other words you
could imagine that if I'm saying all
comma and then there's a function as the
next argument yeah yeah you know Sanders
suggesting background color scaling and
background color function one of the
issues with scaling is what is the
universal set so to speak over which the
scaling is done because you might on the
one hand you might want it for the whole
data set or you might just want it for
some localized region but I really like
the idea of data dependent coloring I
think that's interesting and now yeah I
mean so by the way I assume that in this
right-click menu that you will have a
styling option here I have an
anticipated add now we could be um but I
think you should because I think that
way if you had a yeah if you had a star
option there then it's going to get less
lot less obscure I mean in other words
you're basically filling in these weird
options with the GUI and I can imagine
you're looking at a data set and you
want to highlight a particular piece of
that data set so so let's go through the
workflow here I highlight one of these
things I say okay make it red okay now I
want to harvest that highlighting
programmatic place so to speak right we
talked about this last time and there
were two ways to do that one would be
like a little button at the bottom of
the data set that works like manipulates
paste and the other would be simply to
evaluate the data set okay well either
one is okay with me but I mean they
should both work I think if there's is
there a problem with them both working
but then then what I would get is that
then if I say options of that then I
would get I would then be able to
harvest the thing that was added there
yeah okay you know we've never had a
function called harvest we have so in
reap we don't have harvest in just one
of those functions we could consider
some time um never mind I do think that
um yeah actually two points here so so
[Music]
fit smurfy on our extremis is pointing
out that styling will be more helpful
with themes do we imagine that we should
have some themes for data sets do we
imagine that sure we could do that
I mean I think in particular the themes
would do things like determine the you
know that gray color that's used for the
data set headers and things yeah the
other thing that I could imagine theming
is the way that elision works inside the
cells yeah which is another issue
similar to background is and do you have
a do you have an option which controls
how the illusion is working
yes but it's it's broken right now I
renamed it and apparently something went
wrong okay it was called elisions I
change it to hidden items okay now
sander is making some comment here about
no no or no the RHS of the whole
function what so I don't quite
standard I mean in other words so this
if this is a raw pink okay so the this
is this is now I'm adding a section here
this is some value dependent styling
Idol content dependent styling now let's
talk about what that might be so it
might be depends on a value or it could
be depends on a header because remember
you're showing headers that are words
they may not always be words yeah um
even if they were words one could
imagine doing something where it says
you know do a string match I mean this
also relates to to determine okay so
let's say and depends on value we could
imagine doing something like background
arrow and then some function should be
the right hand side of the rule
I wanted the matching on the left-hand
side you want to do it on the right-hand
side what do you mean by matching what
well you could you could imagine having
like a pattern which would match all
headers that contain e on the left-hand
side and then you know arrow pink yes
but that's I explicitly disallow that
because otherwise you can't make sense
of specs if you get an suspects kind of
assume a a rectangular sub dataset so
that you have a clear notion of what are
the rows and columns successive rows and
columns if you just can match arbitrary
things which are not rectangular you
can't make sense of the rows and columns
and a spec okay but but here if what we
want to do is imagine for example
actually I mean look you could just be
if the right hand side is a function
then it right yeah then it gets applied
to I mean I think that's what Sandra is
suggesting and I kind of agree with that
um shouldn't this be like map indexed in
which the function itself takes two
arguments the value and the position
right well you might want it to take a
second argument at the position yes
which you could ignore most of the time
but even if you given wall it's still
going to index over those things 1 2 3 4
5 etc right so the function could be the
value and the and the extract spec
basically your your part spec paths back
you could conceivably even if your data
set has keys you might want to have
indices and American disease as well as
keys or instead of keys well that's a
different thing so that might be
something else but but in this case
um so let's take a look at what this
would look like we would be saying arrow
you know if hash greater than zero green
otherwise red right mm-hmm that's pretty
civilized it's pretty civilized and
interesting now I don't see any reason
not to do that yeah there now there is a
question of the color function scaling
business I don't think that's relevant
here I don't think this is a you know I
know think it's a plotting story so to
speak I think this is really a literal
value story I know the scaling is
relevant I mean there is a question what
if you want to do this coloring based on
I mean you know the extreme case is but
I think that's silly um I think that's
okay imagine you wanted to run a anomaly
detect on the data set or on a column of
the data set and then based on the
anomaly detect you want to color things
so coloring based on anomaly detect how
could you do that or some other global
criterion okay what I'm saying yeah
perhaps is that the values will not be
numeric in general so they can be very
scared
that is also correct yes no scaling
isn't really the thing my question is
what if you want to pick up what if you
want to do computation because right now
the data set operations that you can do
dig into the content and return a new
dataset based on content but can it
return a new data set with different
styling gender stone what I'm saying so
if I if I were to say something like
this where this data set okay then I
want to say something like um do this
total comma all I think okay not very
exciting for the identity matrix but you
get what I'm saying right but I don't
know anyway well here let's um see what
happens if I'm to saying reverse okay
but what I don't know how to do that
will that will affect the content of the
data set right but what if I wanted to
affect the styling of the data set get
what I'm saying what what if I wanted to
go ahead no I guess you're saying um so
we're using its content dependent
styling dynamically generated content
dependent styling see the problem
metaphore only returns it returns a data
set this returns a data set which has
had its innards munched right but we
can't return a data set that's had its
options munched right now I mean is
there a
metaphor for what to do there so if we
say set options on the data set we can
certainly do that right um so if I say
here if I take that data set and I say
okay what does that mean does that how
should that work I mean this is the
analog of a show I see that's not what
we want to do what we would do is a data
set here correct yes it's a self well
the question is how do we get that thing
to depend on a function of the first
data set well I leave that as a
challenge I'm not sure we know right now
but I can see that that being wanting to
be a thing because it's like okay you
know take this data set find the
anomalies in it and highlight them let
me ask this question if we put if in
data set just like in a graphic the way
we do that is um the
[Music]
the if we were to have a symbolic
wrapper for the content of something so
let's say I were to spray okay if I
sprayed style hash background error red
you know what we have a way to do this
we have this item don't we we have this
mechanism for saying items something or
other here right it grid yeah so what do
we do here item style but is there a way
of wrapping the item it's the thing
itself with an item right no because I
think there's a fundamental difference
between grid and dataset in that respect
grid is a formatting construct data set
you don't want to go in and insert
styling into the data right why does
item why is item something that shows up
there you know what this is not such a
stupid thing
no look this is a way of inserting
metadata into the data set do you mean
at the construction time easily be
removed and placed somewhere else that's
a possibility so in other words let's
imagine what we did was we said item
background arrow red okay and that then
as part of the evaluation of data set
that would be stripped and turned into
an outer option so in other words what I
could do is if I could say here I could
map onto the data set
something that says if the value is
greater than 75 put an item background
red in that's in that position but that
that would then evaporate from the
actual content of the data set and would
migrate to its options
I don't think this is totally stupid
we could do in fact the same thing with
grid if we wanted to it doesn't really
matter because as you say it's purely a
formatting thing I like this idea I
think this is useful because I think
otherwise there's no easy way this is a
quite an easy way to go and say you know
go scan through this data set and
somewhere you know content dependently
color this thing whatever it is take a
think about it I like okay so um sand on
a live stream is commenting that in
Excel there's a a color scale background
that will automatically scale between
min and Max so that is effectively the
color function that's effectively a
color function or a background color
function right I mean so well no it's
pointing out that and I don't have no
idea will automatically skeleton min and
Max but min or max for that column or
min o max for the whole spreadsheet um
well I think that there's a there's a
question here and you know certainly
with this item mechanism you're not
absolutely stuck in terms of doing
something which extracts a column and
then does something to it mm-hmm
anyway let's keep going in your in your
thing I actually really like this idea
of being able to because it sort of mix
as the symbolic way of being able to
sort of represent things with the um yes
so sander is suggesting here that if we
were to say things like all arrow
rainbow as opposed to or or simply color
because that would be essentially color
data rainbow right rather than so that
in fact is using our function idea
yeah that's using our function idea but
not if we could pack into that something
that dealt with the scaling we would be
golden because that way this thing here
this idea up here will already work with
this except the color dated rainbow
doesn't know how to do the scaling if
we're doing color data to a you know one
two three and indexed color that will be
fine that makes sense
no but it's a good idea if it did so
that's a separate where the Rangers get
put oh oh I see they get put inside like
that it's not terrible but it doesn't
have a way of saying get the range
automatically it could I mean I'm sure
that could be an automatic there that
would get the range automatically from
that data
to this clear what this um yeah okay so
that's within a column that's doing that
so you select that okay but I do think I
mean the fundamental point here is
content dependent um I see you specify
the range to color I see I see I see
because it because it works by having a
selection it's a it's a I forget it's a
GUI thing it's not a programmatic thing
so in other words that would be like us
having a way of selecting this and then
saying um by the way why does single
click not do the not bring up a menu
well I'm sorry why does left-click not
but whatever which I would click for me
and because I have a left-handed Mouse
it's the other way around but doesn't
matter but for the ordinary click why
does that not bring up what does that do
on a data set nothing except on a header
which drills down so that's another
thing to discuss is what it should do on
a what even hover should do I don't know
why hover I mean so hover is doing this
down here that's nice but should hover
also put a raft in place that you could
then do something with but giving your
discovery into place for the right-click
basically to get what I'm saying yeah we
so we talked about adding hover menus to
header items but we don't have the
technology to support that currently
okay alright so that's a that's for the
future but it does seem like a
reasonable idea um okay let's let's look
at the last two things well so you can
skip that if you want that's a little
bit of a detour what is it it's
explaining that the background is a
little bit of an exception you specified
separate row and column colors they
blend just like they do in grid
depending on how they're specified so
that you can make these kinds of okay so
what you're saying is in these cases
so normally later wins right except that
if you specify a whole row in the whole
column they blend yes and the only
reason for that is to support this grid
behavior where you can make these you
know grids that are easy to read because
you can follow the rows and columns well
it's nice but I mean I don't understand
why other things wouldn't want to be
blendable as well well I can't think of
another case where that's really useful
I can I mean you've got a whole region
in the data set that is sort of the blue
area and then this one guy in the middle
who's red yeah and you want that to look
different from the red one in the middle
of the green area okay yeah I mean it
seems like kind of a fringe case to me
then it is a bit but I mean I don't know
if you want to do that you can do it
using blend explicitly why do you put
the blend you just but the color yeah
but the fact is that your idea of later
overrides earlier is being violated by
this row and column case well it's not
violated I mean it's a different syntax
right it's depends on whether they're
separate spells but if you gave them as
path specs you're saying they would not
blend if I give two different paths back
yes I'm saying overlap yeah I don't
think that's great so in this syntax
there's a special case where it blends
yeah I mean I can
distinct cases it's not obvious to me
this is correct okay so you're making
the choice that path specs disjoint you
know successor path specs overwrite yes
if they blend you're screwed there's no
way to explicitly say don't blend these
things just use this color how I
understand I understand
well I mean clearly clearly in our
friendly you know world of functions
here we could imagine the case where
this is fun path spec and you know
previous or something okay and and
previous layer effectively in principle
right well that would give us access to
whatever the color so far was yeah it's
perhaps crazy the problem is we can't
really change the I mean by the time
we're doing this it's like we're almost
to feed at feeding the whole Association
into this thing which we don't want to
do because this case is really nice but
we can have we could imagine this you
can imagine this have a think about this
I it may be crazy but ok combining an
overriding style options this is a
related thing it's so if you have items
style there can be lots of different
styles for sizes and bold and all that
so the way I've implemented like styles
override and different styles combined
so that first row is 12-point bold the
first column is 24-point italic so what
you end up in the 1-1 position is bold
italic I understand the blonde e4
overrides 12
seems sensible to me what would I do if
I wanted to go back to the base for you
no but in here what would I do if I
wanted to say this thing is definitively
italic 24 but not bold but but ignore
what came before
I'm just pacified pleasure just for one
item or well I'm wondering if there's an
overall override or whether you just
have to back out I mean it's not very
modular if you have to back out what you
had where would an overall override go
but I don't know I look honestly this is
what style is doing anyway so there's no
real I mean this is no different from
nested Styles yes yeah so I don't think
I mean if if nested styles haven't
bitten us in 30 years this is probably
gonna be okay
okay style options colors override
rather than blend I agree so this is
just pointing out that the top level
list is always interpreted as a list of
specs okay and then
sanity of this more deeply encrusted
creature is that yes yeah gets to be
kind of deep and now just so I
understand if I were to do this and I
were to do a brace brace green yellow
and I would have a magnificent coat of
many colors
yes okay it's lovely
and if I were to do that in a further
insanity how do I get an identity tensor
how do I get a or can I do that with
them
love a Cheeto tensor how do I rank three
do I just do that that's interesting
that that doesn't work I shouldn't that
work I think that should work they
decide of a sparse array should just
work it does work it doesn't look like
it worked I think that Chris I think you
should look at that I think someone
wrong there no it's correct what's good
cuz because that's laid out the first
the first layer no this is right but
this isn't right
no I don't think it's the typesetting I
think it's the latest set itself think
that I just said well I think the data
set just thinks that's one element and
it's the sparse array rather than
cracking open the sparse array I think
it should crack open the sparse array
okay so what you're saying here if I go
down yet another level here and I say
red blue magnificent okay I mean I don't
really know why yeah right okay
um yeah I mean cool because somebody can
give some examples of these I mean this
particular one is it's particularly
useful but Tim might more useful if
these were gray levels and then that
would say that the things that
corresponding to the actually let me
just do that because I'm just curious
what that does oh I see if I were to
just do hold on a second if I were to
just do light pink no this will be
boring light green because there's no
variation this will just be a uniform
color mud color yeah okay but if I would
have very let's imagine each one all
right that's gonna give you alternating
rows yeah right so now I want to do yeah
okay I don't know why that
was that one white I don't know it's
hard I'll have to look at the other I
wouldn't expect it to be wide list no I
mean right missing a level of list yes
that's right so then then what I really
want is our goodness sake why did that
do that why did that do that why did it
give an error well maybe it turns into
real IRA okay okay that's sort of
interesting mildly interesting um okay
data set and grid options syntaxes so in
general you can do in data set which you
can do in grid bet rows and columns are
swamped so in data set in it that why is
that for grid because grid has chosen
that the one argument case is his
columns or what yeah so it's a grid they
for whatever reason its columns comma
rows for the specs
let's probably
it's two columns only right in other
words if you don't give the two argument
to two element form it'll just apply to
call house I suspect that's why there
happens now yeah that's unfortunate I
think though grid is probably not a I
mean there's an argument that we should
take all of the formatting all of the
equipment of I mean it's an argument you
should just use data set as the primary
formatter because it's getting pretty
good and you know it's so often that you
want to do operations on it so why not
allow that
option ro value is equivalent to a null
path spec being that right no passback
just means the top level right but the
second if it was back on arrow pink cyan
comma red green or a comma read for
example whatever it is then that would
no longer be true this is only the one
argument form no it's the naked right
hand side or sorry the the right the
with if the right hand side is not a
list I think now that I think about it
this is only true for item options this
is not true for headers I need to
revisit that this will be magnificent
this way of doing it and this is
honestly a much less insane way of doing
alternating rows I mean this allows you
to do all kinds of wild things with with
them yeah I agree with this that's gonna
take some some work to implement was
gonna require some significant
restructuring
well it isn't necessary for version one
okay okay
on our live stream some unpronounceable
handle points out them Excel alternating
in Cairo colors based on the value in a
column effectively visually group in
common terms content sensitive for
hunting yeah I mean we've we've been
talking about content sensitive
formatting I agree but the question is
how well I mean honestly alternating in
row colors based on the value in a
column visually grouping common items I
entirely understand that seems to me we
should sounds like something like split
applied the styling seems to me we
should do a little bit of discovery of
what spreadsheets have been doing on
this coloring stuff but but I mean
clearly we've got a long way here the
main thing we we we sort of introduced
in this review is the content-based is
content-based styling and I really like
the idea of using item as a flex or way
to do that because item would let you
programmatically add whatever styling
you want and have it not mess up the you
know the the content of your of your
dataset and I think that's a way I mean
I think then we can look at these
different operations I you have to think
about what you do with different
operations like mapping item you know
particularly if item had a curried form
we might be able to do something pretty
nice I don't think item does have a code
form right now it does it um it does not
we are in luck well possibility yeah
much case we don't get the currying
thing but um I think we just have to try
some cases of this I I have a feeling
this is going to work rather nicely and
we may yet find ourselves wanting a
curried form but I agree it's a little
bit of a weird curried form if the if
the you know because normally you would
expect the zero option case to be just
don't apply options so I admit that
that's weird
and may be occurring as a bad idea um
all right great
well that was a nice liberal presented
review um and good so other things with
data set I'm juggling along fine is that
true yeah I implemented some of the
things that we thought about our last
meeting I know I have more to do okay
but I mean all of the robustness with
large amounts of data and things is that
coming in nicely well I'm not going to
attend to that until I get all this
redesigned dollars or cents and trying
to make things efficient is there gonna
change no okay I mean I think the other
big issue is user assistance for
querying datasets because that stuff is
really pretty hard to use I mean it's
pretty hard to remember how that all
works um and it would be nice to I mean
that's the thing we need to explore is
what we can do either with attached
cells or Auto completions etc to help
that stuff yeah okay I mean Auto
completion would be a really good start
like and maybe some stuff is in these
header menus you know maybe we put some
actual operations in the header menus as
well as sorting and things um the other
thing just a coming attraction that I
should mention is the idea of data set
of a relational database right we talked
about that last meeting okay is that is
that in underway is that somebody is
somebody looking at that where basically
you're compiling the data set queries
into the underlying SQL queries
ultimately I searched my do you remember
if I think that was directed towards
someone I mean I don't think they know
that because I just talked to them this
morning yeah yeah I need to send that to
them okay and remember Todd is now
managing that okay um because I think
what we would want to do there is for
simple data set queries that are
successful
we compile into SQL it should just work
in other words I mean just just to be
clear on what we think should work um
you know if I do something like this and
then and then I simply say dataset of
that right then I should make a sort of
virtualized data set we need to know
what it's gonna display here but it's
gonna be some kind of blob that displays
some virtualized data set and then you
should be able to do things like say you
know all come a total here and have that
just work by making sense yes I think
it's almost spectacular to make it work
um and and then the other thing that is
also desired just to be slow on the
roadmap is a CSV file for example or I
think what is more realistic as an hdf
file where we're doing the same thing
where the HDF file is sitting on the on
the you know and the file system and we
then do this okay so I know that CSV
file displays as a data set what do you
mean I mean you can import a CSV file
and make it display as a data set oh I
understand that but what I'm saying is
there's no important involved the things
sitting on the desk oh I see okay that's
that's the Leonid you know processing
data like a snake or something the thing
where you're you're you're chunking the
data you're processing and so on
if that makes sense so in other words
you're never reading the whole thing in
and I believe so that was the discussion
we were recently having and I forget who
it was with about doing that with the
HDF and not being able to do that with
CSV you might ask shadi what the that is
um okay I'm being reminded that tomorrow
is our thursdays are our which talks
developers talking about all kinds of
interesting new things in version 12 and
tomorrow is a um i'm now just trying to
read what this is saying i'm confused
here okay etienne is talking about
machine learning tomorrow it'll be good
check it out okay um alright thanks all
here um very nice sorry please say that
notebook for you closing I just did okay
thank you okay
see you guys soon thanks for the
comments